радниця уповноважена президента України
з прав дитини та дитячою роби літації
Мурат Шахін голова представництва юнісеф
в Україні
ремінь дюфло заступник голови
представництва ЄС в Україні Василь Луцик
голова Національної соціальної сервісної
служби України Кирило невдоха
громадський активіст а також
з нами
колеги підкажуть мені точніше чи з нами
на прямому зв'язку так є Миколай павляк
дитячий амбуцман Польщі Михайло вітаємо
Дякуємо що з нами на прямому зв'язку а-а
Дякуємо за участь у форумі
Отже панове в нас надзвичайно складна
тема тому що вже багато років триває
день інститутулізація Ми багато років
говоримо про те що в Україні мають діти
жити в родинах в сімейних відомах
виховання але по різних причинах за
різних обставин ця реформа затягується
почнемо з заступника міністра освіти
нова команда
чи ось зупинить мене але чи Я правильно
розумію що зрештою десь в день
стотолізації заважає постійна зміна
міністрів постійна зміна
постійна зміна команд Чи ті Це дійсно
так Чи можливо передача ось цієї всієї
інформації далі і спадковість все ж таки
в день інституталізації і розуміння куди
ми рухаємося ну така стратегія якою всі
будуть беззаперечно триматися незважаючи
хто буде при владі Чи це нас приведе які
як як нам уникнути як нам побороти це
затягування Добрий день Вітаю всіх Я
думаю
це дуже таке хороше питання тому що
реформа день спеціалізації триває вона
не зупинялася ніколи просто в зв'язку з
різними причинами в тому числі і
активними військовими діями вона
призупилася ви знаєте щоб зараз ще в нас
є дитячі будинки в нашій системі їх
близько 10 але якщо взяти 10 років назад
і їх було набагато більше і ці дитячі
будинки щороку наповнювалися відвідувачі
вони якісь свята до них приходили до тих
дітей
в гості які приносили їм е-е цукерки
якісь різні подарунки при цьому це не це
не те що саме більше потрібно цим дітям
оскільки міністерстр я представляю в
Міністерство освіти і хочу сказати що
саме освіта є тим е-е основним одним з
основних таких елементів що що ми маємо
забезпечити для цих дітей хотіли також
запитати тому що сьогодні в нас була
дискусія з молоддю і вони казали про те
що є проблеми з освітою в інтернатах Чи
ви на це теж звертаєте увагу що
насправді в інтернатах да за дітьми
можуть із доглядом іноді є питання Так
але з освітою величезне питання от як з
цим ще Тобто нам потрібен вирішувати
одночасно так багато багато проблем так
а є проблеми які тут і зараз І це
інклюзивне навчання так і чи готові ми
до інклюзії от з якими Тому що тут
насправді проблема вона ширша з
проблемою стикаються і родини і діти із
проблемами стикаються держава по різних
причинах тому що є законодавча є
виконавча є багато-багато різних ось
цієї вертикалі яка також складна система
що склад з якими складнощами стикаєтеся
ви і чи є світло в кінці тунелю стосовно
всіх цих питань якщо брати дитячі
будинки основна складність для дітей це
наскільки освіта тому що там працюють
чудові педагоги які відкладають всю душу
в цих дітей але це проблема соціалізації
цих дітей тому що вони не спілкуються з
іншими дітьми вони перебувають в такому
замкненому просторі де вони не можуть
поділитися своїми емоціями з іншими
дітьми отримати від них якісь емоції тут
основна навіть як на нас проблема І саме
день студентація коли дитина переходить
в закритого закладу до сімейної форми
виховання і відвідує звичайно школу є
одним з шляхів вирішення цієї проблеми і
саме інклюзивність звичайних закладів
освіти дозволить перевести цих дітей з
дитячих будинків до сімей і відповідно
надавати їм освіту вже не
спеціалізованих закладах а конкретно
звичайно школах де Діти зможуть сидіти
на уроках разом з звичайними дітьми і
спілкуватися і обмінюватися думками
емоціями досвіду чи зараз Міністерство
освіти залучено до цієї інклюзії
і наскільки в нашій країні зараз поки що
це складно зробити тому що
деколи і суспільство не поки що не
готово до до інклюзії На жаль що для
цього потрібно робити
насправді інклюзія вже впроваджується
багато років багато років іноді ми
стикаємося знову з тими самими
проблемами що іноді нібито дуже
освідчені батьки і ми знаємо що іноді
відбувається в школі з інклюзією навіть
з батьками які нібито дуже
розумні прогресивні але можуть були ти
дитину в київській школі що мене
надзвичайно завжди дивує це виклик для
всіх тому що інклюзії не було наше
суспільство не звикло до того що діти з
особливими потребами відвідують звичайні
школи і тут Міністерство Якраз зараз
розробляє нову концепцію психологічної
служби школи коли психологи які будуть
працювати їх буде більше в школах вони
зможуть зг ладжувати ці конфлікти і
батьки учні вчителі будуть отримувати
якісну соціальну підтримку саме для того
щоб такі конфлікти про які ви говорите
щоб вони не виникали в школах
чи з якими зараз ви стикаєтеся
проблемами як Міністерство що вам що
найскладніше в цій в пришвидшенні
реформа ми розуміємо що реформи гарних
покращень не буває швидких але напевно
от вас особливо в умовах війни у вас є
певна кількість викликів які
які вам потрібно подолати можливо з
іншими міністерствами можливо з з
законодавчими владою можливо що що
не досконало вашій в вашій
на вашій Ниві Давайте так нема
недосконалого Я дійсно виклики які
стоять виклики які стоять перед
міністерством і в частині дітей
які виїхали за кордон яких були
евакуйовані за кордоном це дуже велика
проблема для нас тому що після початку
повномасштабного вторгнення понад 300
дітей були евакуйовані з дитячою
будинків і зараз вони перебувають там за
кордоном в патронатних службах ми як
Міністерство звичайно забезпечує міг
дистанційною освітою тобто вони
навчаються в наші школах але основна
зараз задача повернути їх в Україну і
при цьому створити для них умови в
Україні не гірші ніж ті які перебувають
в яких вони перебувають там за кордоном
це для нас виклик і тут стоїть питання
щодо е-е модернізації закладів в яких
вони перебувають цей з оновлення нового
освітнього простору інклюзивного
безпечного простору це також створення
нового змісту освіти який дозволить їм
реалізувати себе реалізувати свої мрії і
здобути ті професії про які вони мріють
Ми будемо дуже сподіватися що саме так і
буде адже на Міністерство освіти на
нашого нового міністра покладена велика
відповідальність Велика місія і в
реформі і в інституціях І взагалі в
освіті в цілому тому сил вам і натхнення
вашій непростій роботі і можна сказати
що сьогодні ваша професійне часткова
свято так так адже освіта це дуже велика
кількість саме дітей з нами сьогодні на
панелі Сергій дубров перший заступник
Міністра охорони здоров'я
саме Міністерство охорони здоров'я
підпорядковані
будинки дитини які опікуються найменшими
і
в цього року 31 січня уряд прийняв дуже
важливе рішення для того щоб більше
тисячі дітей були влаштовані в сімейні
форми виховання
чи дійсно це відбулося з якими
складнощами стикнулися ви тому що саме
ви є відповідальними за догляд дітей в
медичних закладах які виклики Зараз
перед вами
Ну на жаль на сьогоднішній день не
вдалося реалізувати цю політику і
забезпечити переведення дітей до трьох
років в сімейну форму виховання Звичайно
це пов'язано перш за все з викликами в
яких ми живемо всі з повномасштабним
вторгненням 24 лютого
на початок війни в
Міністерстві охорони здоров'я було 37
дитячих будинків зараз 36 в Житомирській
області два дитячих будинки об'єднані
величезна кількість дітей це понад 590
дітей були евакуйовані за кордон зараз
там перебувають Майже 500 дітей з
дитячих будинків в зоні активних бойових
дій були евакуйовані Вінниччини звичайно
процесу усиновлення і переведення дітей
до сімейної форми виховання воно
уповільнено І звісно основним з факторів
невиконання цієї програми є саме перш за
все забезпечення безпеки для цих дітей
внаслідок бойових дій але ми працюємо
сумісно з міністерством соціальної
політики з національною соціального
сервісної служби
в контексті реалізації цієї політики
станом перед собою плани амбітні до
кінця поточного року хоча б 20% дітей
які перебувають на вихованні в дитячих
будинках перевести до родин
ми вже почали говорити про інклюзивність
і не для кого не секрет що інституційний
заклади це і інтернати для дітей з
особливими потребами і звичайно
ми не можемо не говорити про проблеми
про те що іноді батькам І прийомним
навіть родинам з дітьми з особливими
потребами надзвичайно в громадах складно
немає сервісів Немає роботи з такими
родинами і Ці діти
Зараз під загрозою особливо зараз після
повномасштабного вторгнення зараз Ці
діти під загрозою опинитися в
інституціях опинитися в інтернатах діти
з інвалідністю що робити щоб цьому щоб
упередити цю біду тому що це біда тому
що ми говоримо про те щоби
розформовувати інтернати про
інклюзивність а Зараз ми можемо отримати
і в мене є Навіть цифра 15
дітей перебувають вже в інституціях і в
нас є велика кількість дітей які туди
можуть потрапити Що з цим робити так
дійсно цифра ця перевищує 15 тисяч це 15
647 дітей і Звісно це не всі діти які не
мають батьків частина дітей які мають
батьків але ви абсолютно правильно
говорите що далеко не в кожному регіоні
не в кожній громаді можна надати
адекватний догляд лікування цим дітям
і тут ми Міністерство охорони здоров'я
ми говоримо про створення медичних
центрів реабілітації та паліативної
допомоги в громадах в кожному куточку
нашої країни для того щоб в цих центрах
можна було надавати або денну або
постійно і медичну допомогу і можливість
відпочити батькам цих дітей
і забезпечення освітніх процесів
розвитку цієї дитини в тому числі чи
наскільки це реалісти тому що ми можемо
говорити про плани да А коли в нас була
медична реформа Да коли навпаки все
зменшувалося Да ми тепер хочемо
збільшувати цю частину а-а догляду так
тобто чи є в ресурси чи є в країні
ресурси для збільшення чи є такі люди
які будуть чи навчені вже тому що це
невідкладна проблема да ми не можемо її
вирішувати роками що для цього потрібно
зробити чи є цей ресурс держави
потенційно-ресурс наразі є досить
високий ми маємо друзів міжнародних
партнерів той самий фонд юнісеф якому
хочете подія хочемо Подякувати І за
проведення моніторингу потреб дітей які
буквально вчора позавчора завершився
дітей стосовно потреб
кожної дитини
ресурс є і розуміння стратегії цієї
також є і я думаю що найближчим часом ми
вже зможемо реалізовувати політику
створення центрів реабілітації це є
зрозуміло що це питання не там одного чи
двох років але з чогось треба
розпочинати і вже в цьому році ми готові
розпочинати створення таких центрів
хочеться в це
вірить що такі такі процеси не будуть
затягуватися тому що сказати чесно
особливо мені болить те що в державі так
повільно все відбувається Я розумію що
це не тільки проблема нашої держави це
проблема в цілому державних структур і
апаратів і всієї але ми як е-е як країна
у війні маємо реагувати іноді швидше і
іноді нам дійсно потрібно щось щось
робити реактивніше на всіх рівнях будемо
сподіватися що це в нас вийде пані Дарія
Герасимчук радниця уповноважена про
президентів справах дітей також вітаю
вас з вашим професійним святом Нехай
зниклих безвісті загиблих дітей нехай ця
статистика більше не росте нехай от
Цього дня Хочу побажати вам щиро нехай
ця статистика буде в нашому жахливому
минулому пані Даша ви з перших днів
війни опіку
опікуйтеся проблемами дітей ви створили
і сайт які є власне
підрахунком цієї жахливої статистики
діти війни в чат бо дитина не сама що
дала змогу родинам які хочуть прихистити
і хочуть всиновити хочуть стати батькам
опікунами подати цю заявку цей чат-бот
насправді став рятівним на початку війни
коли напевно кожному з нас ставили
питання як всиновити як прихистити
дитину Да щоб ви знаєте про реформу
зсередини ви знаєте про дитячі будинки
сімейного типу без багатьма знайомі
особисто ви знаєте про їх біди і болі ви
знаєте про
внутрішньо переміщених про те що з ними
відбувається якщо викресли ви
виокремити проблеми родин переміщених
роди взагалі
проблеми сімейних форм виховання зараз
тому що ми говоримо про те щоб цих форм
щоб цих сімей ставало дедалі більше але
щоб їх стало більше ми маємо показати
приклад Що диви- дивіться як круто бути
де без те які проблеми зараз у дитячих
будинків сімейного типу прийомних сімей
щоб ці проблеми вирішити поки всі ми тут
можливо їх запам'ятати щоб таких родин
ставало більше щоб надихати прикладом
Дякую Катя так і таке дуже гарне
представлення Я свого боку також хочу
подякувати вам за ту роботу яку провели
ви проводите ви тому що насправді Я
впевнена що всі повинні знати про ваш
проект дім для дітей це важливо і дякую
вам дякую Лері Татарчук і фонду твоя
опора Дякую що ви почули відчули І
сьогодні я мала нагоду побачити з
родиною вранці яка отримала в подару від
вашого проекту будинок тому я дуже вам
дякую родини потрібно підтримувати Дякую
Катю а хочу якщо відразу ми конкретно
перейдемо Давайте до проблем то як на
мою думку ці родини з якими спілкувалася
Я найбільше говорять про те що їм дуже
складно без підтримки комплексної
підтримки тому що я як мама у якої одна
дитина так з інвалідністю Але я маю одну
доньку підліткового віку і я часто свою
це дуже важливо так і я часто розумію що
мені потрібно психологічна підтримка Я
шукаю По партнерам по колегам запитую
колеги Дайте будь ласка психологу бо
психолога тому що Ну вже потрібен
контакт Я сама не ок так а часто там
звертаєшся до колег по освіті Тому що
інколи також були проблеми з освітою з
медициною з багато- з багато в багатьох
багатьох сферх насправді Але якщо ми
говоримо про прийомну сім'ю або про
дитячий будинок сімейного типу ми
говоримо про дуже велику кількість дітей
коли у тебе цих проблем множиться Ну
просто в рази відповідно тобі потрібна
підтримка психолога то би й потрібна
тобі як мінімум Тобі потрібен
кейс-менеджер до якого ти можеш
зателефонувати і сказати у мене проблема
з такою з такою дитиною там по в
напрямку охорони здоров'я а тут потрібна
консультація по освітнім питанням а тут
по соціальним послугам і так далі і
відповідно оце саме той момент якого
дуже не вистачає батькам вихователя А
якщо ми говоримо власне по розумінню для
того порозумінню цієї взагалі проблеми
чи цієї роботи давайте назвемо так цієї
роботи да як це бути батьками
вихователями як це бути прийомними
батьками Як бути усиновителями Чому люди
не завжди до схильні Чому вони не йдуть
і тут ви сьогодні згадали про чат-бот
дитина не сама це власний був такий
момент дати людям точку входу де вони
можуть почути що таке дитяча будинок
сімейного типу що таке прийом насіння що
таке усиновлення розібратися в цьому
повчитися і отримати інформацію от тут я
думаю що нам теж дуже важливо розвивати
оці соціальну послугу підтримки навчання
інформування і коли просто громадяни
України побачать що є ціла команда
супроводу ти будеш не один тому що мені
здається адекватним людям
їм насправді завжди страшно І вони
завжди невпевнені в тому що вони точно
зможуть вони йдуть і кажуть А раптом я
не зможу і кажуть Ну ми тебе підхопимо о
класно Ну окей Тоді я піду ті люди які
кажуть давайте мені за два тижні дитину
я жіночу установити дайте негайно чому у
нас дітей не роздають просто так чому я
не можу взяти 25 дітей бо я впевнена що
я можу швидше за все А ці люди не
оцінюють адекватну свої здібності і свої
сили Так свої сили в вихованні дітей
тому що це також складно вас свій
власний є досвід є досвід менторства
також дорослого хлопця з інтернату Зараз
Ви відчуваєте рух в тому що суспільство
готове так само як на початку війни на
початку повномасштабного вторгнення був
такий підйом того що ми всі хочемо
всиновлювати Ми хочемо розбирати дітей
зрозуміла що це було таке інфантильне
перше бажання і нерозуміння ситуації яка
зараз ситуація чи готові українці
ставати прийомними батьками чи готові
створювати дебати
столиці готові до цього в яких відсотках
чи цих готових до такого Випробування
українців тому що ще раз розкажу про
Сьогодні я бачила цих прийомних батьків
у сховищі ну це герої це Дід - це батьки
з десятьма маленькими дітьми в мене двоє
Я не можу з ними впоратися своїх Вони
мають дають Раду 10-тьом отаким кнопкам
тому чи є така кількість українців які
готові на такий подвиг для задля дітей
задля держави задля того щоб ці діти не
жили в інтернатах а спочатку відповів на
частину з приводу власного менторства Да
якщо це можна так назвати Катю ви
занадто багато про мене знаєте
Насправді Я не вважаю себе ментором Я
швидше вважаю себе другом так сталося що
я вчасно з'явилася в житті одного хлопця
з яким ви також вже знайомі я просто
з'явилась в його житті і стала його
другом в той момент коли він уже майже
досяг свого повноріччя і на сьогоднішній
день це вже дорослий хлопець якому
необхідно спілкування з дорослою рідною
людиною в якого взагалі нікого більше
немає І це класно Я можу бути такою
людиною моя родина Мій чоловік ми готові
бути друзями і це класно ми допомагаємо
один одному Чому б ні що стосується чи
збільшилась кількість людей які готові
приймати людей дітей в свої родини так
на початку повномасштабного вторгнення
коли українці побачили так багато дітей
яких ми почали евакуйовувати з різних
закладів особливо коли вони побачили
маленьких дітей з будинків дитини вони
побачили і сказали Боже мій скільки в
нас дітей їм треба негайно знайти родини
вони мабуть щойно втратили батьків Бо ми
ж не знали що у нас є стільки дітей які
мають статус сироти чи позбавлений
батьківського піклування і це це просто
відкрило очі українцям Нарешті Про те що
Це оці закриті установи в яких зростають
діти так їх можуть там любити там може
бути хороші вихователі Я не заперечую
але там і є ті хто знищує особистість
дитини раз і назавжди з маленького і
коли наші українці побачили таку
кількість дітей Звичайно вони
захотіли негайно допомогти дітям Це
добре Так це можливо дещо було
занадто реактивна така дія але це добре
І зараз я бачу що так бажаючих
прихистити дитину свою родину або
розуміючих людей які проблеми і виклики
будуть попереду стало більше з чат боту
дитина не сама А ми отримали понад 24
тисячі заявок від громадян України є а є
Вибачте є відсоток Хто отримав дітей
дойду до цього І власне 24 тисячі
громадян подали заявку що вони готові
прихистити свою родину дитину на умовах
тимчасового прихистку а потім коли
отримали люди інформацію про цей Скажем
так варіант да зрозуміли що Не зовсім
він підходить тут теж Важливо пам'ятати
друзі що коли ми говоримо про
сім'ю для дитини ми завжди повинні
пам'ятати що це повинна бути безпечна
сім'я дитина не іграшка її не можна
віддати сьогодні в одну сім'ю Завтра
забрати скотині тут ми помилились на
тобі сюди а тому що ми розуміємо що
кожна людина яка каже Ой так довго
проходить процес усиновлення Ця людина
не задумується і вона не думала не мала
насправді поганих намірів ті люди які
кричать
що треба швидше вони просто не думають
про те що є люди з поганими намірами А
якщо ми говоримо далі то потім ми
запропонували людям надати заповнити
розширену заявку після того як вони
ознайомилися з цією інформацією і вже
понад 9 тисяч заповнимо тобто не 24,9
потім ми запропонували навчання і там
було навчання про різні форми і ось з 3
000 майже 3000 осіб родин які пройшли
повний курс навчання
80% пішли
ремонтувати документи в прийомні батьки
батьки-вихователі в усиновителі тобто
вони просто проходили навчання щоби
тимчасово прихстити дитину але Отримавши
адекватну інформацію вони пішли Куди
треба тому сьогодні я хочу ще раз
подякувати міністерству соціальної
політики хочу подякувати звичайно юнісеф
за за те що так швидко відгукнулися на
мою таку спонтанну ідею створення цього
чат-боду і досі продовжують
забезпечувати реалізацію цього проекту
тому що це це вже далі не моя справа моя
ідея перейшла в чудову реалізацію
класних людей професійних тому за це я
дуже-дуже дякую Ну і хочу зауважити що
ця ідея з'явилася дуже швидко Це було в
перший місяць повномасштабу в перші два
тижні тому що негайно потрібно було
реагувати на цій дуже великі
повідомлення часто неправдиві
повідомлення там 200 дітей з Херсона які
щойно втратили батьків приїхали в
івано-франківськ негайно їх усиновлюємо
і так далі от щоби направити людей в
потрібне русло щоб вони знайшли десь
місце і власне і так само був створений
портал діти війни щоби люди мали єдину
точку входу де вони можуть отримати всю
інформацію так дійсно тому що багато
спекуляцій багато дезінформацій багато
застарілої інформації з якою ми також
стикаємося в своїй роботі тому цю
інформацію потрібно перевіряти ось якась
портал діти війни там є абсолютно
перевірена інформація далі Дякую дуже
знову також на панелі Мурат Шахін голова
представництва юнісе в Україні п мурате
юнісеф довго ретельно плідно підтримує
реформу денстотуалізації розвитку
сімейних форм виховання зараз Наскільки
Ви бачите прогрес наскільки ще потрібно
ваших зусиль і наскільки ви бачите
Наскільки Ви бачите
результативність І що ще потрібно
зробити щоб пришвидшити ті процеси які
можна звичайно пришвидшити
чудово
буде з колегами представниками
профільних міністерств і з дарією яка
координатором і і представниками
мабутьманасеф для нас честь бути з вами
і мене вражає те яким чином віддані
українці
на данню і моїх і ми хочемо поділитися
своєю доброю волею
несев У нас є багато співробітників які
працюють у вашій країні ми тут були і
перед війною і під час війни і наступні
роки ми тут будемо щоб допомагати
українським дітям
жити європейським життям є також
європейські партнери які допоможуть
здійснити дитячі мрії і потенціал кожна
дитина
про яку ми говорили під час конференції
присвяченої міжнародними дитячими дні
має право на здоров'я і освіту тобто
візія дуже чітка це право має
здійснитися і всі інституції і всі
установи зобов'язані робити цю роботу
для дітей
на сьогодні третій ранку Ми прокинулися
від обстрілів діти бігли до
сховища 11-річна дитина загибла ми маємо
запобігти тому щоб діти вмирали щоб діти
ставали жертви щоб вони втрачали свої
родини ставали сиротами ми маємо
покращити збільшити нашу роботу в нас є
відповідні зобов'язання також від таких
чемпіонів провідників цієї роботи Як ви
Катя і також у виконанні реформи Я хочу
призвати до інституціоналізації до
кращого догляду щоб не було таких
викликів у
сім'ях які виховують дітей на
міжнародному рівні Я бачив відповідно
візію і зобов'язання і відповідно
юридична платформа має передбачати
покращення
відповідно фінансування на сьогодні
100 при сімей виховань 200 будинків
дитячого типу по всій Україні з сходу на
захід вони сьогодні могли поділитися
своїми досвідом і проблемами з якими ми
стикаються
щоб ті хто приймають рішення
міністерствах послухали і сказали ми
виправимо ці проблеми ми будемо з вами
працювати над цим і далі сказала про
більше ніж 200 000 сімей які сказали і
ми хочемо відкрити наші двері поділитися
хлібом і зобов'язатися для того щоб
виповнити
мрії цих дітей - це велике зобов'язання
це велике зобов'язання у від Харкова до
волиня від Херсона до Одеси Я бачив
мерів з цих міст і всі вони брали
зобов'язання щоб відкрити свої
відповідні дома для дітей і надати
послуги соціальні для дітей і сімей і
дуже важливо запобігти розлученню дітей
і ми можемо як ми можемо надавати
соціальні сервіси
послуги родинам із дітьми-інвалідами нам
потрібно Також
запобігти розлученню відокремлення таких
дітей від сімей і маємо подивитися як це
зробити як це реалізувати також в
Україну найкращі світовій практиці
напрацьовані тут і також компанія по
поширенню обізнаності по підвищення
обізнаності
і є чудові лідери по просуванню таких
реформ і треба багато ще людей які могли
показати як і могли поділитися відкрити
свої дома і прихистити діти і юнісе в
зобов'язаний і працює з урядовими урядом
України на всіх рівнях з президентом
з ЄС є там також дуже багато донорів Я
думаю ми
скористаємося цією книгою як можливістю
для покращення життя дітей і маємо
надати
маємо зупинити руйнування дитячих садів
шкіл і вбивства дітей
обстрілами Давайте будемо разом
працювати в солідарності для того щоб
надати краще догляд з кожної дитині
краще освіти виховання кожній дитині
невтомну підтримку тому що дійсно кожна
кожна дитина має мати саме родину і
Родинне виховання і родинне піклування
незамінне нічого але пан Мурат дуже
гарно зауважив на тому що превенція
важлива і ми іноді забуваємо про це що
іноді врятувати
родину від сепарації від того щоб дитина
була здана в інтернатне виховання іноді
можна навіть не іноді просто на це
потрібні знов-таки соціальні працівники
соціальні служби більше і більше більше
послуг тому що дійсно зараз в умовах
війни не всі витримують навіть на
міцніші люди найміцніші батьки і
найміцніші мами можуть можуть бути
можуть бути не тільки в злиднях можуть
бути просто не в формі не в батьківської
не в батьківській формі так сказати
дякую дуже і з нами на прямому зв'язку
Миколая павляки дитячі боцман Польщі ми
в першу чергу хочемо подякувати Польщі
за всебічну підтримку українських дітей
українських родин і зараз Міжнародний
день захисту Польщі хочемо побажати і
польським дітям які стали такими самими
друзями нашим українським дітям які
прийняли їх в в школах в класах хочемо
також побажати мирного неба здоров'я і
батьків поруч
пане Миколаю хочемо запитати досвід
Польщі тому що Польща давно перейшла до
форм сімейного виховання в Польщі є цей
досвід який ви можете розділити з
Україною а що потрібно робити
якнайшвидше А що Україна вже може робити
тому що ви знаєте українську систему як
вона працює зараз Які ваші
бачення реформування
Дуже дякую за ваші побажання я передам
їх у Польщу польським дітям і я приїхав
до вас саме з нагоди цього свята вчора
під час конференції з паном боцманом
лубенцем у присутності вашого президента
Володимира Зеленського ми вже почали
говорити про дітей про те яку величезну
роботу Ви виконуєте для того щоб
повертати своїх дітей і я дуже вам за це
Дякую Ви сьогодні усі дитячі обутсмени
вже рік як вона з'явилася оці
омбудсмени і незважаючи на цю страшну
трагедію сьогодні о 3:00 вночі коли
руські бомби впали на Мирне місто але у
день захисту прав дитини треба бажати
дітям нових мрій радості і миру діти
повинні переживати такі трагедії а
повертаючись до вашого питання Я хочу
подякувати що сьогодні так багато людей
зібралося пані Оксана яка була в мене в
Варшаві представники юнісеф все це
відбувається і відбулося дуже швидко ми
в Польщі вже декілька років
концентруємося на різних формах
виховання у родині але це зовсім
непросто тому що ми уряд міністри можемо
писати дуже гарне
законодавство ми можемо навіть у
Конституції це записати але чогось може
запрактнути чого
навіть не стільки соціальних працівників
суди напевно також симфори нам потрібні
чутливі родини мами
батьки які хочуть поділитися своєю
домівкою Але перед усім хочуть
поділитися своїм серцем без цього не
буде працювати Ані система Ані найкраще
законодавство якщо не буде людей які це
зроблять і саме війна російська агресія
призвела до того що дуже багато людей
відкрили свої серця це люди в яких немає
власних дітей або вони вже виховали
власних дітей і хочуть тепер прийняти
дітей які стали сиротами
в Польщі ми вже багато років Стараємося
щоб не було так званих
дитячих будинків вона згідно з
законодавством в одному місці не може
бути більше 14 дітей є ще такі центри де
виховується більше дітей але і в нас в
Польщі І в вас в Україні і я думаю що
зараз це таке звернення до людей які нас
дивляться Можливо сьогодні зміна пишуть
про нашу конференцію
Можливо ви хочете поділитися своїм домом
Можливо у вас є вільна кімната Можливо
ви можете прийняти братів сестер які
залишилися без батьків внаслідок війни і
Ці діти мають бути разом не можна
розділяти родини і тоді ми реалізуємо
базове право дитини з Конвенції про
права дітей у конвенції написано що Діти
повинні виховуватися в родині отже
давайте забезпечимо дітям родини
звертаючись до як найширшого кола
дорослих
що стосується нашого досвіду це наші
діти склали цей складний іспит тому що
вони не просто
запросили за свою шкільну парту віддали
свій комп'ютер наші діти
поділилися своїми кімнатами деколи наші
діти
перейшли спати у вітальню на дивані А
свою власну кімнату віддавали своїм
українським друзям і коли я черговий раз
про це говорю в мене знову з'являються
мурахи на тілі тому що діти склали оцей
іспит на гуманність і тепер ми дорослі
повинні також скласти такий іспит щоб
забезпечити дітям опіку законодавство
законодавством конвенції конвенціями Але
у всіх
країнах є родини в яких немає власних
дітей або діти вже дорослі і якщо вони
візьмуть до себе дітей на виховання нам
всім на урядовому рівні буде легше це
врегулювати гроші на це завжди
знайдуться ось Стокгольмі ми вже про це
говорили відбулася зустрічна найвищому
рівні я постійно у контакті з нашою
міністеркою вона буде виступати і
розповідати про наш польський досвід я
можу вас запевнити що ми
намагаємось продовжувати підтримувати
українських дітей так само як і своїх ми
бачимо що їм смутно що вони хочуть
повернутися додому і якщо це буде
безпечно то у співпраці з вашими
органами влади ми будемо дітей повертати
але допоки є така необхідність щоб ваші
діти залишалися у Польщі то знаєте що
Польща для них справжня Дякуємо Дуже
дякуємо так дійсно польські діти здали
цей іспит на гуманність ділилися з
українськими І продовжують ділитися з
українськими дітьми всім і це от
надзвичайно Добре що в цей день День
захисту дітей ви ще раз про це згадали
тому що ми маємо в дітей вчитися вчитися
ділитися вчитися
вчитися бачити і вчитися дружити і
напевно цей світ був набагато кращим
якщо б ми просто вміли бружити і вміли б
поважати кордони одне одного і вміли
бачити гарне в людях а діти вміють одне
одному бачити саме гарне і від цього
відштовхуватися пане Михайло Дякуємо
дуже дякуємо що долучилися до нашого
форуму також разом з нами ремії д
уповноважений у справах і заступник
голови представництва ЄС в Україні пане
Ремі
Ми багато говоримо про один століцію
є питання яке хвилює більшість є і ви
зараз скажете це так Чи не так Чи
візьмуть Україну в ЄС якщо ми не
позбавимося
інституційних закладів Чи це тільки
пропозиція І це тільки натяк на те що ми
маємо це зробити але в нас є на це роки
чи в нас нема цих років
це дуже коротке але дуже складне питання
Це тобі комплімент
Ви отримаєте відповідь цю відповідь каже
що
проєкти і ЄС він зосереджений на дітях і
жінках це соціальний проект перш за все
наша соціальна економічна модель описує
заснована на третій статті 3 і ідея
полягає в тому щоб забезпечити якість
життя для тих хто живуть на території
Союзу
якість життя найкраще вимірюється тим як
ми відновлюємося до найвразливіших
верств нашого населення і звичайно все ж
таки
діти є одними з найвразливіших верств
і в нашій країні члени мають
відповідним чином забезпечувати і
захищати права дітей і
з огляду на те що шкода
інститутилізації дітей була
задокументована на протязі тривалого
часу ми вважаємо
що йде кращий спосіб доглядання дітей
з використанням
сімейних виховників
сімей будинків сімей дитячого типу і
будинки сімейного типу відповідно навіть
два роки тому Рада Європи
прийняла рішення створити
у кожній країні членів
забезпечити безкоштовний доступ всіх
дітей до освіти і
медпослуг і здорового харчування у таких
домах звичайно ж діти потребують
особливого лікування особливо
догляду і лікування і ось ця платформа в
рамках якої Ми намагаємося працювати І
як назва вашої конференції це і наш
лозунг сім’я для кожної дитини оцими
намагаємося забезпечити коли
її вразливі сім'ї ми допомагаємо їм
уникнути розлучення і передачі таких
дітей і в
інтернати і перехід до цього принципу є
також частиною перед і передумовою яку
ми розглядаємо
коли
будь-яка країна хоче вступити у сім’ю ЄС
якщо подивитися на вашу країну кандидат
і я вітаю всіх українських громадян це
великий де Сьогодні ми цим дуже
пишаємося Це честь для нас прийняти
Україну як країну кандидат наступним
кроком Як ви знаєте будуть перемовини
про вступ і коли ви пройдете цю цей етап
Я сподіваюся що це буде вже скоро ви
побачите що відповідні розділи у цих
переговорах дев'ятий розділ стосується
соціальних принципів і він говорить про
інклюзію говорить про дітей про захист
прав дітей
це не можна сховати Це питання як інколи
можна там якісь проблеми приховати Тобто
це питання має бути публічним і воно має
бути вирішене і говорячи про
зобов'язання
дійсно велика мотивованість велике
зобов'язання є на підтримку
зусилля згідно ж таке це нелегке нелегка
проблема це також проблема грошей
фінансування гроші є Я думаю колеги з
міністерства говорили про відповідну
наявність ресурсів для цього я також
впевнений і далі я це підтвердить що у
резерви України щодо доброти і співчуття
не обмежені треба тільки все інше
влаштувати і зробити так щоб
активність члени суспільства діяли в
одному напрямку разом із владою щоб це
не було серйозної проблеми і ми дуже
раді допомогти рідше знайти рішення і
допомогти дітям Увійти у цей
важкий світ коли президент фонд була тут
у лютому вона зобов'язалася допомагати
цій реформі обговорювала з друзями
партнерами також і юнісеф як найкращим
чином використовувати цей бюджет Я думаю
ми вже близько до цього підходимо і дуже
скоро буде проект запущений для
підтримки координаційного офісу в рамках
Кабінету Міністрів
який власне буде забезпечувати щоб всі
сили були спрямовані в одному напрямку
для того щоб реалізувати цей проект У
нас є також проектна територія ЄС для
допомоги українським дітям які
проживають там там також є проблеми
відповідні потреби вирішувати допомагати
І звісно ж таки ми не забуваємо про тих
дітей які були вкрадені і примусово
переміщення до Росії це вчора
обговорювалося тут
на конференції І звісно ж таки ми будемо
співпрацювати з Україною щоб допомогти
найти рішення і репатріовати цих дітей і
найкращих умовах це наша спільна
відповідальність І на завершення
Дозвольте мені сказати що ми
підтверджуємо нашу повну Солідарність і
зобов'язання для спільного просування
цієї реформи ми
маємо таку
Відмінно відповідальність щодо
реалізації цієї реформи ми зобов'язані
Ми хочемо і зобов'язані тому що побачити
Україну в ЄС і я думаю що Україна цього
заслуговує Ми дуже сподіваємося що в нас
вийде все і в тому що ми переймемо
досвід Європейського Союзу тому що є
Тіка є ті країни які не так давно
пройшли цю реформу і ті країни які з
якими можемо взяти за приклад і Ми
впевнені що І зараз пані міністр Оксана
жолнович зараз має
відрядження саме і перейнятті досвіду
також реміджем Дякуємо дуже дякуємо і
дуже сподіваємося на швидше прийняття
України як повноправного члена
Європейського Союзу дякую
також разом з нами Василь Луцик голова
Національної соціальної сервісної служби
України пане Василь сьогодні саме про
сервісну службу тут багато було розмов
саме багато було розмов саме про послуги
про те що не вистачає людей
розкажу зі власного досвіду з того що я
чула від родин так що іноді просто у
соціальних працівників не вистачає часу
сил не можуть добратися до тих родин які
вони мають надавати послугу тобто брак
людей - це велика проблема чи це так як
це подолати і чи має
сервісна служба оцей проект розвитку
наскільки вам треба збільшитися
Наскільки треба збільшити фінансування
Наскільки треба мати більший апарат щоб
сервісна служба стала
найкрутішою в світі
Дякую Катя за таке поставлене питання ну
в першу чергу треба зауважити що дійсно
ці проблеми які поставлені вони є давно
так і держава повинна думати яким чином
вирішувати це тому що коли ми почнемо
буде окковувати територію тобто теж
постане питання того що повинні бути теж
соціальні працівники які будуть надавати
ці послуги і якраз тобто те що ми
говоримо і те що говорили наші сьогодні
іноземні колеги збережені сім'ї це теж
робота в соціальних працівників тому чим
більше нас буде соціальних працівників
тим більше ми будемо зберігати йти в
сім'ях А тих дітей які ми вже
влаштовуємо сімейні формування будемо
надавати сімейну форму виховання цей
супровід коли ми говоримо про нашу
службу тобто в принципі наша служба - це
коронуючий орган який забезпечує захист
прав дітей Тобто ми не даємо
безпосередньо соціальні послуги але наше
завдання розвинути цю політику так щоб
було достатньо цих працівників і щоб всі
послуги які наються в першу чергу ми
перевіряємо якість надання цих послуг
так тобто що коли працівник виходить те
що ви кажете дійсно сім'я була
задоволена від того що він прийшов і він
виконав своє завдання як
це сказати тому що я впе
внена що брат тих хто вчить так і брак
кого вчити і брак тих людей які хочуть
працювати в таких послугах і ми
розуміємо що в принципі в соціальній
сфері На жаль поки що в нас немає тренду
на модність працювати в соціальній сфері
На жаль можливо зараз війна внесе свої
корективи але що що потрібно зробити що
потрібно зробити на шляху аби все стало
краще Ну на жаль Ви праві що дійсно поки
що ця професія не в тренді так тому ми
рухаємося в декількох напрямках перше
завдяки міносвіти ми зараз з ними
працюємо над розширенням державного
замовлення на спеціальностях якраз
соціального працівника друге завдяки
юнісеф ми запускаємо пілотні проекти
зараз У декількох областях для того щоб
розвинути послуги тобто підтримки сімей
тобто цих областях і виявити ті проблеми
тобто і скажемо ці заохочення можливо
для працівників чому спеціальну сферу і
будуть працювати в цій сфері завдяки
онісеф ми підвищуємо спроможці місцевих
громад саме для того щоб вони розуміли
для чого створювати в них у місцевих
бюджетах одягу також надання соціальних
послуг і третій напрямок який ми
здійснюємо в цьому це відповідно
підвищення
спроможності служби у справах дітей
оскільки саме вони є цим гарантом
місцевому рівні тобто щоб і соціальні
послуги вчасно надавалися і права дитини
було забезпечені і відповідають вони
також за усиновлення дітей і в
скажімо виведені сімей із складних
життєвих обставин Тому цей комплекс є
звичайно Як ви правильно сказали тобто
переорієнтування після перемоги і
можливо під час війни коштів державного
бюджету на підвищення заробітної плати
працівникові в цій сфері теж приведе
нових людей які зможуть якісно надавати
ці послуги
Дякую дуже чи бачите ви швидке
поліпшення на цій Ниві Чи це знов-таки
чи дійсно в бюджеті знайдуться гроші чи
є увага держави на це чи є політична
воля про яку ми так багато говоримо тому
що в нас на жаль без політичної волі
процеси не відбуваються і потрібна Ось
ця
загальна увага до проблеми чи ця увага
до проблеми є і ви її відчуваєте як на
мене проблеми це завжди зараз фокус і як
на мене зараз є по першій політична воля
і всі учасники на які сьогодні на панелі
які сьогодні з нами онлайн Мені здається
вони всі на одній хвилі і рухаються в
одному напрямку щоб це зрушилось І ви
говорили про повільність державного
апарату як на мене зараз війна показала
що ми можемо діяти швидко і оперативно і
зараз всі ситуації які в нас виникають
по захисту прав дітей Вони вирішуються
ну найближчі години тобто під час
поступлення інформації і це якраз теж
кооперація всіх учасників які для
якихось основне забезпечення краще
інтереси в дитини тому я вважаю що якщо
ми будемо рухатися в такому темпі тобто
зокрема і з такими ж намірами ми
все-таки не розтягнемось на довгі роки в
найближчим часом ми бачимо вагомі
результати І це буде якраз теж підстава
щоб Євросоюз сказав що ми дійсно скажемо
так виконали все що ми вважали за
потрібне тобто І ми готові бути членом
Європейського Союзу
яких сервісів не вистачає чи є ті
прогалини так в сервісах тому що ми
сьогодні говорили про інклюзію наприклад
да І ми говорили про те що потрібно
більше психологічної наприклад підтримки
особливо зараз які корективи в сервіси
внесла війна Чого яких не вистачає людей
для того щоб в родинах було
більше більше оцієї турботи про яку
казала Дарія Мені здається що Дарія
правильно підмітила про те що в нас
зараз якраз потрібно розвивати послуги
до зокрема Як інклюзії так і постійного
долю з дітьми з інвалідністю так і зараз
в нас як варіант тобто коли в нас діти
перебувають в інституційних закладах Так
в нас є така форма як малі групові
будинки так і це якраз є один способів
можливо тобто покращення умов дітей з
інвалідністю які перебувають в
інвестиційних закладах
раніше їх оці якраз тобто установи крім
того тобто коли ми говоримо Про
соціальні послуги тобто напевно в першу
чергу
у Верховному війни Це дійсно
психологічна підтримка тобто і розвиток
на різних рівнях тому Якраз зараз тобто
міністерство соціальної політики і ми
також долучаємося створюємо проект
пілотний так для того щоб
психологічна підтримка була доступна для
всіх тобто зокрема вона була зручна і
скажемо я сподіваюся що найближчим часом
дуже побачити результат цього проекту
сподіваємося Дякуємо Дуже вам бажаємо
натхнення в роботі тому що робота
складна і потребує масштабування так і
великого польоту думки якого також
потребує кожна робота Дякуємо дуже
Кирило невдоха громадський активіст
людина яка багато років займається
проблемами інтернатів і на власному
досвіді знає що таке інтернатне
виховання що таке жити в інтернаті
переймається
долями дітей щоб перебувають в
інтернатах і не тільки
крило ми вже говорили в нас вже була
розмова сьогодні перед офіційним
початком і ви говорили багато про і
ваших однолітків зараз які випустилися з
інтернатів і тих дітей які перебувають в
інтернатах чому важливо саме щоб
інтернати зникли А щоб вони не
перебудувалися в Новій інтернати щоб
вони не перебудувалися і це назвати
реформою так тому що є і ми знаємо і У
декого і такий план тобто як чому це
настільки важливо от від вас хочеться
почути тому що ви людина яка була в
інтернаті і ви точно знаєте чому
Дякую всім
насправді мені приємно що держава
нарешті
почала вести діалог зокрема з тими Кому
вона своєї допомоги нашкодила
моє становлення як особистості
відбувалося через прагнення довести
прагнення довести біологічні сім'ї що я
заслуговую на їх любов прагнення довести
однолітком однолітком які зростали поза
межами інтернатної системи яких ми
бачили за стінами
які ми бачили в Ютубі
нє YouTube тоді для нас закритий бо в
інтернет ну в закладі до Яна ця довести
що Я не гірший за них я такий самий я
така сама дитина я така сама людина Я
хочу ходити в магазин купувати речі як
ну робити ті ж справи Як Ну що мені
хочеться
прагнення довести суспільству Чи я може
бути корисним тобто 17 років Я
розвивався всупереч а не завдяки тобто
держава витрачає купу коштів мільярди
коштів на те щоб я розбивався завдяки я
і ще тисячі дітей але насправді ми
розвиваємося всупереч А дехто і не
вистачає сил і енергії і можливо
мотивації можливо якоїсь такої
певної складової яка навіть всупереч
допомогла б розвитися Тобто ми маємо
велику проблему і Я мріяв про батьків
поруч Я мріяв про любов про піклування
я не просто мріяв про любов я прагнув
відчути що таке любов тому що коли
приїжджали волонтери і вихователі то
любов проскакувала але миттєвість тобто
тут добре я далі розповім як цю любов ми
купували буквально вихователів
я прагнув і я мріяв мріяв не прагнемо
мріяв про обмін емоціями переживаннями
про те що в мене всередині так як це
робить звичайна дитина з батьками
Я хотів просто бути індивідом не масою я
хотів бути особистістю
Так зараз я вважаю що я став особистістю
але це всупереч
А тепер завдяки негативному цьому
досвіду Я тут щоб такі дитячі долі як
моя і тисячах дітей
Вибачте
не мала повторень в сучасній Україні і
не треба нам говорити не на часі В нас
війна А за що ми тоді боремося і
насправді інтернатна система і те що
зараз ми суспільство нарешті побачило що
може відбуватися з дітьми це тривало
роками в інтернатній системі Це тривала
в закладах освіти які мають
цілодобове перебування зараз купу реформ
зараз всі заклади освіти за ну зокрема
там де надається освітні послуги всі
позмінювали навички статуту ой навички
стати назви але насправді все залишилось
те саме тому що при мені змінювалася 23
рази назви і статута але підходи і все
таке інше залишалося на тому срібні
тобто як сказав представник з Польщі
тоді дійсно ми можемо писати ідеальні
закони але вони не працюватимуть Якщо
система існуватиме у ці заклади
інституційного догляду ну мають масовий
підхід от щоб ви не говорили які б
наукові доповіді не писали представники
даних закладів Вони все рівно це масовий
підхід це е-е ну тобто сама система вона
не здатна забезпечити
індивідуальні потреби так як це робиться
в сім'ї вона не здатна Ну не спрямована
на особистість і кожного індивіда
інтернатна система найважливіше не
формує емоційної психологічної стійкості
тобто що про що ми можемо говорити про
яку хімію математику в освіті чи ще десь
якщо не сформована емоційна і Дитина
просто приходить на пару вона не розуміє
що вона робить в цьому світі Що вона
робить На цьому уроці І що від неї хоче
вчитель навіть якщо Вчитель це буде з
трьома з двома вищими освітами там
науковий ступінь і таке інше тому
психолог зараз мій найкращий друг
розумієте
постійна любов підтримка з боку батьків
важливіше за подарунки та гарні умови в
інтернаті
оскільки ніщо не може замінити теплоту і
безумовно прихильність яку надають
батьки
знаєте коли нам благодійники волонтери
привозили подарунки
тепер перше що ми робили це
передаровували цей подарунок працівнику
інтернату щоб купити на якусь миттєвість
на якусь хвилинку їх любові теплоту
щоб купити почуття
або ж продавали цей подарунок
працівнику інтернату чи іншій людині
знайомі і таке інше щоб піти за власні
кошти
придбати собі щось аби тільки це зробити
самостійно
як це роблять діти звичайних сім'ях яка
та сім'я не була
найчастіше Це була шумо купувала це Міна
морозиво цукерки І це при тому що в нас
було п'ятиразове харчування і це при
тому що благодійники звозили нам купу
подарунків тобто усе вирішувалась для
нас без нас
І знаєте що замість того щоб боротися за
будівлі та збереження інтернатів для
працівників
ще на позавчора обласні місцеві ради
адміністрації
мусили б створювати все охоплюючи якісні
соціальні послуги які допомагатимуть
дітям знаходити нові сім'ї якщо це
необхідно а не найважливіше підтримувати
біологічні сім'ї це може бути
всиновлення патронатна сім'я чи прийомна
в нас тут зараз певним чином через оцей
це бот який не раз згадували певного
комунікація з'явилася але її недостатньо
насправді дуже багато людей прагнуть
установити або хоча б взяти під опіку
дітей але в нас не достатньо комунікація
ми говоримо що дуже багато проблем цими
дітьми але насправді мені трошки
пощастило що в 11 років
працівник-інтернату до якого я бігав щоб
мені дайте мені цукерку дайте мені щось
домашнього поїсти чи просто відчути
якусь підтримку це охоплює чи він Якби
він послухав це те що йому казала
директорка мого закладу і вихователі
який я такий-сякий Він би ніколи не взяв
мене в свою роди Зараз ми з 11 років і
зараз мені 23 ми підтримуємо досі
контакти Я на вихідні на свята і коли
маю час приїжджаю і
вони певним чином компенсують те
втрачено любов підтримку саме в сім'ї я
навчився е-е прати речі правильно ходити
до магазину купувати собі будь-що тобто
нас в закладів вчили прати речі
Показували що таке порошок але не давали
Нам це робити ну тобто про що ми можемо
говорити
це може бути також Родинна реабілітація
як соціальна послуга це соціальна
послуга курси відповідального
батьківства в нас взагалі відсутня ця
комунікація на місцях
інформаційна юридична психологічна
підтримка для дітей та батьків фінансова
та матеріальна допомога наприклад
допомогти відновити житло чи купити
ліжко та стіл для навчання дитині тобто
в нас Міністерства готові фінансувати за
конституційного догляду там і столи
закуповуватися що
1 вересня постійно оновлювати приміщення
А дитині купити в сім'ю а ліжко вона не
може розумієте не може тому що Ну як це
весь сім'я ви батьки йдіть на роботу
заробляйте А дайте як заробити батькам
не всі знають тому що ми дуже часто це є
випускниками інтернатного закладу або
методів які використовувались в
радянщині розумієте тобто батьків ніхто
не вчить як правильно бути батьками і це
також проблема
соціальна реклама в нас її недостатньо
Ми хочемо щоб діти брали дітей брали в
родини але як то ну тобто немає
комунікації немає комунікації з
суспільства немає комунікації з дітьми
Ми можемо зараз дуже багато говорити з
вами на цій панелі Що там у нас немає
родин немає сімей Ми не можемо ну всіх
дітей забезпечити родиною
якщо в нас буде правильно комунікація Ми
почнемо комунікувати В громадах в
селищах то в нас дуже багато сімей
насправді можуть надати опіку і вони
нададуть Їй набагато ліпший краще ніж в
закладі інституційного догляду Тобто ми
заклад інституційного догляду там Добре
там дитині безпечно а сім'я яка Можливо
там е-е ну відсутнє
простір який там прописано в
законодавстві це Окей ну це абсурдна
справді тобто
я зараз договорю Тобто ми маємо те саме
харчування ми готові забезпечити
п'ятиразове харчування в закладі
інституційного догляду з цим меседжем
потім вихователі і працівники
інтернатних закладів їздять по селах і
збирають дітей замість того щоб в школах
забезпечити хоча б одноразове харчування
обід для дітей розумієте
ми маємо перестати
платити причина почати шука бути
можливості
як то правлять правну роблять знаєте В
нас дуже багато чиновників депутатів
Вони шукають причину А чому ні А чому ні
А чому важко А чому складно А хоча від
них безпосередньо залежить створення цих
соціальних послуг Наприклад замість того
щоб їздити по громадах і критикувати
Владу і прийомні сім'ї записувати
відеоролики різні там і комунікувати ну
з тим месенджером щоб все в нас погано
витрачати при цьому купу грошей на
бензин на персонал який тебе буде
обслуговувати ці поїздки на харчування
можна було оплатити роботу соціального
працівника додатково в громаді можна
було просто підтримати сім'ю там ті ж
гроші які витрачаєш наприклад постійно
на поїздки чи ще на якісь речі які по
факту не допомагають то міг би суттєво
допомогти
ви розумієте саме дитина має бути в
центрі уваги а не будівлі та працівники
працівники якщо ми сидимо думаємо що з
працівники вони втратять роботу Ну ми
розуміємо що в депутатів це потенційні
виборці але їх же ж можна перенавчити і
сказати що добре йдіть соціальну службу
Ідіть в центр надання соціальних послуг
якщо ви дійсно фахівці якщо ви дійсно
володієте ну тобто в звичайну школу мало
Йде система інтернатної от дуже мало
тому що там некомфортно тому що там
некомфортно Хоча якщо вони говорять що
вони мають фаховість то вони б мали б за
звичайних школах надавати фахову
підтримку тим же з вчителям як
комунікувати з дітьми з інвалідністю як
комунікувати з дітьми з сімей складних
життєвих обставинах як мені кувати з
дітьми які з прийомних сімей з дбст
якби
моя сім'я насправді була вчасно
підтримано вона б мала б прийшла в курсі
відповідально батьківства Наприклад чи
там де вона мене залишила ніби надали
фахову Що дивіться Давайте ми вам
підтримаємо вам фінансів не вистачає А
давайте ми вам допоможемо знайти роботу
таку яка буде здатна забезпечити і вас і
мене як маляв тобто їй ну тобто ну
відмовляєтесь добре позбавляємо вас
батьківських прав і на цьому все за тому
фінансуємо Державну систему яка типу
доглядав мене розумієте
і ну і важливий меседж також знаєте чим
більше інтернатів тим більше воно як
тим більше там дітей буде от чим більше
якщо
волонтери благодійники і держава буде
спонсорувати заклади інституційного
догляду називайте Як хочете підходить і
все інше залишається тим самим тим менше
буде спокуси туди віддати дитину Бо
насправді ми в закладі інституційного
догляду не лише діти сироти та діти
позбавлені батьківського піклування якщо
ми глянемо статистику і не лише діти з
інвалідністю їх там не не ну не не всі
100 000 їх там певна частина і вона Ну
суттєва але не не найголовніша тобто
хочете допомогти дитині дійсно Візьміть
її в родину оце найсуттєвіша допомога
Або можливо спрямуйте сім'ю яка б могла
б взяти цю дитину яка можливо хоче
дитину собі а не але не можу яка
наприклад має думки але немає Ну кроків
які треба зробити для того щоб взяти
дитину або просто заданайте організації
яка працює з сім'ями яка
виконує можна сказати обов'язок держави
і шукає сім'ї
комунікує з сім'ями і потім ми маємо
успішні випадки коли дитина
зростає в сім'ї
або підтримайте сім'ю що опинилася у
складних життєвих обставинах яка живе
поблизу вас бо вона реально якщо це
сім'я складних життєвих обставинах Вона
має ризик бути величеною до закладу
інституційного догляду або мати
небезпеку навіть біологічні сім'ї просто
підтримайте і морально-інформаційну
комунікаційну може Ну і тоді ми не
будемо думати де ж кудись дітей діватись
в інтернатів як інтернат і закрити і нам
варто також зрозуміти важливу місію і
дійсно міжнародне я був
в Молдові в Чехії Щодо обміну досвідом
як вони реформували заклади
інституційного догляду
і нам не треба спиратись що вони там
покращили інтернат і давайте ми покращим
інтернати там Все буде добре покращення
інтернатів це не допомога дитині А от
покращення роботи соціальних служб
створення соціальних послуг на місцях
Якраз це суттєва допомога саме дитині
і
Розумієте я свою дипломну роботу буду
Мабуть писати якраз про те скільки
грошей держава вкладає в дитину
неефективно Тобто вона вкладає тисячі
грошей мільярди грошей дитину на
зростання в закладі інституційного
догляду але вона по-перше не отримає
нічого від того тому що ця дитина не
здатна а потім себе самостійно
забезпечити піти на роботу яка
роботою яка не буде тіньовою бо дуже
часто
випускники і дуже часто закладів
інституційного догляду Вони працюють на
шабашках так би сказати в домах в людей
які ну дають їм або поїсти або якусь
копійчину тобто вони не можуть цих
грошей потім платити податки і запобігти
потраплянню дитини до інтернату значно
ефективніше та дешевше ніж витрачати
сотні тисяч гривень на її перебування в
інтернаті і отримати як я вже сказав на
виході людину яка не тільки не
виправдовує очікування держави
а найголовніше платників податків Тому
що чиновники розпоряджаються грошима але
наповнює бюджет платники податків
звичайна сім'я в якої держава надбирає і
надалі і надалі Правда воно не розриває
порочне коло воно створює порочне коло
отак все відбувається система за
системою тому на мою думку пора державі
перестати відкуплятися від дітей
чи ми знов-таки повертаючись до вашого
досвіду ви достатньо радикально
налаштовані Ну і взагалі молодь більше
радикальна Ну скажу Так що я особисто
теж більше радикально налаштована Мені
здається що іноді дуже Ось такі сміливі
кроки да ну як приміром діє наш
президент і це коли він дуже сміливо і і
в очі каже людям дипломатам те як є як
як є насправді це дія Тому можливо Іноді
на державному рівні більше реактивні
заходи вони також діють
ваша думка е поправте якщо я не права що
потрібно все ж таки закривати скоріше
інтернати не тягнути з тим щоби спочатку
налагодити ще більше родин зробити а
потім подивитися Тобто ви ви ваша думка
що все ж таки потрібно закривати
інтернати і влаштовувати дітей Тобто це
мають бути паралельні рухи
Я за комплексність і за паралельний рухи
Але ми не маємо акцентувати як деякі
чиновники акцентують Хай інтернати
будуть і давайте сім'я це має бути все
паралельно це Тобто ми інтернати маємо
перевести в соціальні послуги створення
соціальних послуг держави повне ресурсів
Вона просто має проаналізувати куди вона
витрачає і перенаправити їх і
перенаправляти треба не після перемоги А
при направляти в ці ресурси вже треба і
вже треба створювати послуги бо я скажу
в коментарях в закладах інституційного
догляду дуже багато дітей які сімей
навіть з тих же ж прийомник сімей здебст
але
інтернат каже що ми вам забезпечимо
п'ятиразове харчування ми вам допоможемо
дитину підтримати соціалізувати Тобто це
має бути паралельно і не треба нам
інтернати зберігати і сім'ї тобто поки є
інтернати поки є і Спокуса бути там
дітям оце найвисові що треба
дякую Дуже дякую за цю таку молоду думку
і головне щоб ця думка є експертною на
мою дум- на мой погляд тому що у вас є
власний досвід І ви точно знаєте що ви
як вже громадський активіст зробите все
щоби вашу долю не повторювали ще тисячі
українських дітей Дякуємо що є такі як
ви Дякуємо що є така активна молодь і
мені здається що саме майбутнє за тим
щоб таких людей ставало більше Які
прухали вперед ідеї ідеї і дуже хочеться
щоб
в свою чергу прислухалися до такої
молоді аби дійсно
цей процес відбувався швидше є дуже
вдячна всім панове за цю дуже важливу
дискусію Мені здається що ми отримали
багато відповідей на питання і разом з
тим ми розуміємо що в нас є одна спільна
мета одна спільна мета - це щоб кожна
дитина все ж таки мала родину І дуже
хочеться щоб за рік ми з вами зустрілися
таким складом і зрозуміли що за цей рік
ми не тягнули не думали як би зупинити
якби
покращити життя інтернатіба що ми дійсно
отримали більше родин більше щасливих
дітей в родинах і ми отримали дійсно
дійсно
результативність від того щоб про що ми
сьогодні говорили Дякую дуже Ну а нашим
глядачам хочу сказати про те що ми ще
маємо панелі наш форум триває
і також в нас є невеличкий сюрприз для
всіх учасників форуму для наших глядачів
в нас є записане відеозвернення від
посла доброї волі Орландо Блума голіву
актора який був з візитом в Україні який
був з візитом дитячих будинках сімейного
типу які звернув на це увагу і
українського суспільства що також було
надзвичайно важлива і зараз він має
кілька слів до цієї важливої дати кілька
слів до учасників форуму а також до
батьків і дітей увага на екран
Ми в гостях Наталії та юрії у них
п'ятеро власних дітей і вони всиновили
ще чотирьох дітей які є рідними братами
і сестрами
просто неймовірно скільки любові та
уваги вони отримують
під час війни прийшло таке от розуміння
що насправді людині дуже мало потрібно
для щастя Ми займалися кар'єрою щоб мати
якісь там достаток і таке інше А потім
ти починаєш розуміти що єдине що Має
цінність - Це родина діти
[музика]
кожній дитині потрібна сім'я в якій
можна відчути любов і захист в якій
можна стати частиною спільноти та
відчути стабільність
[музика]